entrances
are blocked and surveillance is total as
we haven't been able to get much closer
but there are still faint traces to be
found
potential evidence for what critics say
is cultural genocide something
china denies there's a few more of them
than there are of us so
we're stopping here this is a place
where the dead are paved over
and the living are equally silent
fled china with her family in 2016. they
were from hotan
and her grandfather was buried in a
cemetery there
is a
[Music]
she asked us to see what had happened to
the cemetery
[Music]
some of it is obvious a vast recently
expanded prison complex
visible from the air as we flew over
xinjiang
and in hotan there is the predictable
government escort
up to five cars followed us during our
visit
tawazim cemetery where murghaba's
grandfather was buried
to begin with we weren't sure we even
had the right place
there was simply nothing here so
megabet talked about this cemetery as
being full of tombs ornaments
all sorts of decorations people coming
here and bringing flowers
so very busy place and you look at it
now
there's none of that left it's all been
completely erased
but i was wrong we just had to look more
closely
pay more attention we found the wrecked
wooden structure
of a grave marking pummeled into the
earth
this is a building where bodies would be
wrapped in white linen before burial
apparently shuttered and then this
the man who said he owned the plot
stopped us from going further i
oh yeah look at that that is actually a
graveyard in the ground bleach white
a bone six different experts who looked
at this image have told us it is most
likely a human bone
the thigh bone of a child
but these were the only traces we could
find if the cemetery that once stood
here
on the other side a park has been built
with a monument proclaiming ethnic unity
but satellite images show what was here
before and how it has changed
in 2018 there were hundreds of graves
then in 2019 they started disappearing
until none were left
we shared what we had found with murga
killer
the cemetery is not a one-off but part
of a program
we worked with experts to understand
satellite images of the city
the changes they show are stark another
cemetery
much bigger called sultanim has been
paved over
and turned into a car park the tall
islamic style tower on the town bazaar
in the centre of the city
has been taken down and a mosque has
also been bulldozed
the site is now in use again converted
into another car park
on the ground the effect is even more
severe this
was what the hectare mosque looked like
and this
is now the destruction of sultan and
cemetery is even more vivid
a void carved out of the old heart of
the city chinese state media has said
that the cemetery has been moved to the
outskirts of town
this is what's left of sultanum cemetery
and this is as close as we can get as
you can see
it's a huge construction site we can't
get down to where
the graves used to be but you can see
the same buildings in the background
here and they're digging
very deep foundations the rest of the
cemetery over here has been turned
into a car park for a nearby hospital
this was once a very very important
place and simply there is no trace left
on religious sites are framed as
a way to reduce uh
extremism uh despite the fact that
these sites tend to be sort of very
ordinary parts of the
local community and and uh local
tradition
but taken all together what it looks
like is an attempt to
completely re-engineer uyghur culture
there was one more religious site we
wanted to visit a shrine in the desert
that usually at this time of year
attracts hundreds of pilgrims
we found multiple entryways blocked
we've got our three friends watching us
we haven't been able to get much closer
so we're just going to go about
two and a half kilometers on foot and
see if we can get to this shrine
the shrine is also a tomb of one of the
earliest muslims to arrive in the hoten
region
a symbolic ancestor of the uyga people
even in the desert though we were not
alone
we were being tracked but we pressed on
at this stage we're about 200 meters
from the shrine
the chinese government says it welcomes
journalists
so much for there's a few more of them
than there are
of us so we're stopping here going back
another two kilometers
we don't know we're already away very
much eating daikon
then wait a minute
we asked the chinese government for a
response to our questions but did not
receive a reply ahead of broadcast
at a news conference in march in beijing
a spokesperson for the xinjiang
government said
the constitution of the people's
republic of china stipulates that
chinese citizens enjoy the rights to
have religious belief
no government organizations social
groups or individuals
shall force them to have or not to have
religious beliefs
not how they discriminate against people
having or not having religious beliefs
all legitimate religious activities are
protected by the country
for uighurs themselves it is simply
another blow upon blow
[Music]
memory for now still endures but it is
under attack
in xinjiang tom sky news hotel